Walmart took this big decision to stop
selling any merchandise with the
Confederate flag why was that the right
move well first of all our hearts and
our prayers go out to the victims
families into all the people of
Charleston as it relates to this
decision we really just don't want to
sell anything to defense people and I
was surprised actually we carry some of
these items through our marketplace
which has third-party sellers online
we've got over 7 million items so when
we saw that they were out there we
decided discontinue it you know the move
really does appear to sort of be part of
a growing trend of Walmart really
sticking its neck out on social issues
trying to do the right thing I'm
thinking about what happened earlier
this year with the governor of Arkansas
a lot of people credit you personally
for going to him and criticizing the
religious freedom law for getting them
to amend it why is Walmart trying to do
the right thing here and is it good for
business yeah well first of all we need
to always remember that we're retailer
we're merchant and that that's our
business but we do look for places to
make a positive difference in the world
and there is such a thing as a double
bottom line so whether it's the wage
increase or it's what we do with
environmental sustainability trying to
eliminate waste or have energy that's
more renewable all those things are
aimed at running a better business and
doing good things for the world you have
a fabulous personal story with the
company you have been there for over 22
years I believe you got your start there
as a high school student in the summer
in a warehouse you are arguably the most
prepared person for this job since Sam
Walton the founder actually ran the
company himself you've now been in the
top job for 16 months when you look back
is there anything that you think maybe
you weren't prepared for yeah some of
these social decisions you know
Walmart's become a big company and we
try to keep it simple and run it like
it's small but there's so much happening
that seems like every day there's some
sort of surprise and and judgment comes
into play but I don't do it all by
myself we've got a great team to work
with and we really are sincere about
trying to use the company's platform and
a way to do good now our core mission is
to save people money so they can live
better we think that's a very important
purpose to have in life but we also
employ a lot of people we want to have
great jobs yeah we want to use the
policies of the company to help create a
more sustainable supply chain
and all those things are good business